vous allez faire connaissance avec une
nouvelle voiture tout terrain
diane 6 méhari de citroën sa carrosserie
en plastique et thermoformé teinté dans
la masse
matériau miracle élastique et résistant
[Musique]
le moteur 3 chevaux 6 102 centimètres
cubes refroidissement à air puissance 33
chevaux
[Musique]
la vienne 6 méhari c'est un petit
véhicule économique qui s'adapte à
toutes les situations et peut
transporter 400 kg
[Musique]
notre cameraman roland gotha a pris le
volant pour apprécier la maniabilité de
la voiture
la légèreté du plastique fait que la
voiture ne pèse que 525 kg et la
suspension permet une adhérence et une
tenue de route remarquable exemple ce
ses prises de vue réalisées à bord de la
voiture par l'autre autre cameraman paul
fougerolles et ce nouveau véhicule peut
contenter une gamme importante d'usagé
entreprises de travaux publics
agriculteurs hôtelier mareyeurs service
de surveillance artisans maraîchers
chasseurs pêcheurs touristes j'en passe
et j'en oublie
[Musique]
à